gunshots in central vienna
oh my god several gunmen opening fire at
six locations in the austrian capital
one assailant armed with a rifle filmed
walking down an alleyway and shooting a
bystander
many others were injured in the attacks
[Music]
sadly the shooting started first we did
not know what it was
but suddenly people who were sitting in
others guest gardens
started to run first we kept standing
there because we didn't know what was
going on
then there was a shooting again but
closer so we started to run away
because we did not know if we were
running in the right direction
we ran into a hotel and hid there
the austrian chancellor described it as
a repulsive terror attack
this is not it is of course a very tense
security situation
while we pursued the perpetrators we
notice they are very well equipped
with automatic weapons very
professionally prepared it is definitely
a terrorist attack
police killed one suspect and said at
least one other got away
the public has been warned to stay home
and avoid public transport
my name is if it is possible except for
professional reasons and other important
reasons please stay at home
second avoid the city centre and third
there will be no compulsory school
attendance in vienna tomorrow
the attacks happened when many were
enjoying their last night out before new
corona virus restrictions start on
tuesday
the shootings took place near vienna's
main synagogue which was closed
it's unknown if it was the target we
still do not know
what is behind that attack what kind of
group
it is if this is a radical islamists who
have done it which we have seen in
france now or in brussels
in the last years so this is not clear
european leaders condemned the shootings
including french president emmanuel
macron who said europe must not give up
in the face of attacks several people
remain in hospital
some critically and while one attacker
remains at large
the question is who are the gunmen and
what was their motivation
emily stew al jazeera